thank you very much indeed for
keeping ukraine in a top and uh
delivered the truth about the
uh russian aggression in ukraine and
about how brave and heroic is ukrainian
to protect our soil to protect our
future to protect our freedom and our
democracy
we are in the center of kiev
we are
here uh to protect ukraine
and the russian position is about a
little bit more than two kilometers from
here
uh this is
very difficult uh
to explain what does it mean in the 21st
century in the middle of europe
to be awakened by
the russian missile attack by the
russian air bomb attack
when
the
people are shouting and this is the
civilian who is suffering a lot from the
disastrous russian aggression i
first of all i would like
to thank
west for support because this is the
great demonstration that ukrainian
people are not alone and the only scene
of ukrainian people is just we want to
be free
we want to be democratic and we want to
return back our country to the european
family and with that situation we have a
putin putin who
hate ukraine and hate ukrainian and with
that situation uh he launched an
aggression and
for the last 72 hours
more than 3 000 russians were killed
more than 20 planes were hit
more than 100 tanks were destroyed and
more than 1 000 on personal carrier was
destroyed and this is the demonstration
how ukrainian army how ukrainian
soldiers and how ukrainian people uh is
absolutely cancel break putin's scenario
of blitzkrieg
we again demonstrate that
despite of the fact that we were
not prepared for this aggression
ukrainian people are
definitely not accept putin and
we make a decision that civilian
members of the
battalion of the territorial defense
receive the weapons and today
in the
kiev the putin will meet hell
and the russian people and the russian
soldiers who come here to kill
ukrainians will pay
the uh big prize but so we should
understand that this war is not about
ukraine this boy is about
you our dearest dear partners about the
west about free world because everybody
no nobody knows where tomorrow will
appear putin and that's why your
assistance your effective
contradiction to the putin's aggression
is vital for us ukraine we're standing
two kilometers from the russian troops
so as a former president you personally
uh have a weapon you have a gun and you
are prepared to fight
uh uh on the streets of kiev the
russians when that happens is that going
to be in the next few hours if they're
only two kilometers
away we already have uh
russian troops in this distance for more
than 24 hours
and
our battalion is
meeting the enemy on the most difficult
regions our soldiers participating in
the
freeing from russian paratroopers the
stonewall
airport we
meet russian soldiers on the
entrance from the oberlon district we
now uh participating in the uh
securing the governmental quarter or
securing the mayor uh
building in kiev and that's why this is
a very responsible mission and i'm
together
with the
uh my uh
people with the
enthusiam with the volunteers
from the kiev who come here to protect
the independence and we're waiting the
important steps from our allies from our
partners we wait in the strengthening
the sanction and i'm very much happy
that just a few minutes ago
we receive the
information that there is no any uh
nation in the european union who can
block introduction the sanction to
switch russia off the swift payment
system this is the way how we should
make a pressure on putin to not only to
press the prize but to motivate them to
stop the aggression and to withdraw
russian troops from ukraine we are
waiting from our partners
the
action for
blocking and arrest russian plane in the
airport of the
nato member states and eu member states
because this is effective states to
arrest their ships in all of these ports
of eu and nato to deliver the to
introduce the non-flying zone uh above
ukraine because again i just want to
remind you that this is a disaster to
hear during the day during the night the
air alarm uh
evidence in the the russian bomber
player uh
hitting the bomb russian cruise missiles
attacking the cities of ukraine
on that point sorry to interrupt because
i'd just like to ask you about that
point about the no-fly zone uh if nato
uh uh brought in a no-fly zone
ultimately that could mean nato forces
shooting down russian aircraft surely
that would lead to world war three
definitely not because this is ukrainian
sky and we should
we have a full
power on the international based on
international law to
introduce any regime on the sovereign
ukrainian territory including our
airspace and uh with this situation this
is just a prohibition
for russian plane using
our airspace
in a violation of the
international law we should introduce
absolutely any steps who can limit the
aggression who can support
ukraine and
we
would be very much happy if it would be
not nato anti-aircraft system but
the
all member states to give to ukrainian
soldiers the anti-aircraft system that
we can protect our skies by ourselves
apollo apologies apologies you've said
um recently that putin is not only mad
but he is evil
as well and you've already alluded to
the fact that this may well not stop at
ukraine does he have ambitions beyond
ukraine
definitely yes and this is absolutely
different understanding what happening
uh in ukraine year 2014 and what's
happening uh in year 2022 because putin
uh he
lives in the
borders of the warsaw pact
for him the borders of russia finishing
for example in dresden when he served as
a kgb agent uh during his
kgb career but i have a feeling that he
still remain the kgb officer and this is
his understanding of the world order and
world order for him is a russian order
and
no nation can feel themselves in the
security if they have a
putin as his neighbor so with this
situation that can be uh i don't know
baltic states poland romania bulgaria
but the real uh place for putin is not
central in eastern europe there is real
place for putin is the
uh military tribunal in ghaq
and this should be responsibility for
the dozens of thousands of ukrainians
which were killed directly by putin
order
and finally uh finally are you holding a
a weapon now do you have a weapon in
your hands when do you fear that you're
going to have to use it
i don't have a weapon in my hand yet
but i have it with me
and
i do it uh with a great pleasure to
protect ukraine and uh if we do not
attack anybody
we do not do anything who can uh
harm any country or any territory but
definitely we uh do our best that
to protect our future
because our future is a future as a
member of european union our future is a
future
as a member of nato and uh definitely we
should use any opportunity to
uh protect our people to protect our uh
our
uh soil
i have with me this
by the way
austrian uh
weapons as uh glock
uh but uh this is the not our main
strength we think that the
decisiveness of our soldiers
decisiveness of our armed forces
decisiveness of our
uh soldiers who attack russian tank by
the way by the american javelin by their
british and swedish-in-law
and significant number of the russian
tank were destroyed during the last 72
hours is because of your assistance
please increase your assistance please
we need the uh protection
armored jacket we need the helmet we
need the anti-tech we need anti-aircraft
we just need to increase our defensive
capability to stop the crazy uh
aggressor in europe how worried are you
about bloodshed how worried are you
about those civilians who are right now
we have footage of civilians in ukraine
building molotov cocktails getting ready
to fight people with no training or very
little training prepared to do what it
takes this is going to be horrific isn't
it for the civilian population of
ukraine no
look uh because we live in this
condition for already eight years
we have a war not a frozen conflict but
the hot war we have
and the ukrainian person you know pays
an enormous price we know who is a
russian aggressor putin said that in
ukraine they he the people will meet
russian soldiers with the flowers
and preparing the molotov cocktail
this is the flowers for putin
and definitely
this is our soil this is our country
this is our people and putin has nothing
to do here
get out from ukraine mr putin
appreciate your time uh and uh we wish
you uh the very best former president of
ukraine petro poroshenko uh thank you so
much
please speak
in focus
thanks a lot